the NFL Washington Redskins are
defending a controversial decision to
add a player who's been arrested for
domestic violence twice linebacker
Reuben Foster is accused of pushing and
slapping his ex-girlfriend in a Florida
hotel room on Saturday the former
first-round draft pick was cut by the
San Francisco 49ers after that arrest
Washington picked him up two days later
Jan Crawford is outside FedEx Field in
Landover Maryland the home of the
Redskins Jan good morning well good
morning you know because of this ongoing
criminal case now the NFL has barred
foster from playing or practicing with
this new team but he's still allowed in
club facilities and the Redskins say
they hope a new environment will help
this talented but troubled linebacker
turn things around the Washington
Redskins did what no other NFL team was
willing to do claim Rueben foster off
waivers head coach Jay Gruden he was one
of my favorite players in a draft
defensively as a player and one of my
favorite interviews as a person what's
happened since then
I don't know officers say they arrested
Foster after a verbal altercation with
Alisa Ennis his on-again off-again
girlfriend turned violent Saturday
my phone broke II it slapped me in my
face
Gruden acknowledged Foster may never
play for the team there's no guarantee
he's ever gonna step foot on a football
field here but we would like to find out
more about what happened Deborah s Dean
has advised the NFL Players Union on
domestic violence issues they didn't
wait to see how this played out they
just grabbed him up this isn't the first
time Foster has been in trouble with the
league in February Ennis accused foster
of dragging her by her hair and punching
her in the head she later told
authorities she lied about those claims
and the charges were dismissed but the
incident led to a misdemeanor weapons
charge against Foster to which he pled
no contest he was also arrested on a
marijuana possession charge in January
and those charges were also dismissed
the NFL eventually suspended him for two
games at the start of the season
yesterday Foster's former University of
Alabama teammates
who
I'll play for the Redskins came to his
defense through everything I've seen of
him in college I've never had a problem
I've never seen any problems out he's a
great person people are looking for him
to fall good by looking for him to make
more mistakes but you know many human we
all made mistakes nobody's perfect the
NFL has faced criticism for its handling
of domestic violence in 2014
Ray Rice was initially suspended for
only two games after he assaulted his
then fiancee and a casino elevator
Commissioner Roger Goodell later
apologized omitting the punishment fell
short if the National Football League
wants to do something to meaningfully
eradicate violence it cannot be that the
only consequence for a player who was
arrested multiple times for assaulting
his girlfriend is that he's let go by
one team and immediately picked up by
another team now we reached out to
Foster's agent for comment but we
haven't heard back but critics of the
Redskins have been quick to point out
that the team refused to give a second
chance to another 49ers cast-off
quarterback Colin Kaepernick even though
the team needed a quarterback
Kaepernick of course led those protests
against police brutality across the
nation beyond a lot of people are making
that comparison as well at the very
least is a questionable decision right
from an optic standpoint from the
Washington Redskins you may never play
for the Rhodes kids as the coach pointed
out